اصبحت في الاسابيع الاخيره مشبعه برمزيه
سياسيه للجانبين الاوكراني والروسيه وفقا
صحيفه واشنطن بوست واوضحت ان السيطره
بالنسبه لروسيا تعني الترويج لنصر هي بامس
الحاجه اليه لاسيه مع ان قواتها فشلت
بالاستيلاء على مدينه رئيسيه منذ الصيف
الماضي اما بالنسبه للاوكرانيين بخبط تشكل
حصنا وايقونه للمقاومه الخارقه بعد ما زار
هذه المسكي اواخر العام الماضي وجعلها
ركيزه خطابه امام الكونجرس الامريكي كما
ان نجاح هذا الهجوم المضاد سيظهر استمرار
الزخم في ساحه المعركه وبالتالي لاحتفاظ
بالدعم المحلي والدوري غير ان الصحيفه
الامريكيه حذرت من الاستنزاف حصار بخمه
القوات الاوكرانيه واسلحتها واختها ما يشل
طبعا قدرتها على شان هجوم مضاد منتظر على
جبهه اخرى وابدت القلق من ان تعرقل تكلفه
القتال من اجل باخمود الاستراتيجيه
اوكرانيا لهذا الشتاء او الربيع المقبل
هذا وحذر خبراء من اي انسحاب تدرجين من
باخمت اوصل لدار المجاوره او ترك الجبهتين
بحجه المواقع غير الاستراتيجيه نظرا
لاهميه هذه المناطق الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]